three two one action in free education
use submitted by Fuego fire Bernie
Sanders wants to cancel 1.6 trillion
dollars in student loan debt
what you against this didn't a little
bit say this first warns was some Bernie
basically outdid her by saying everybody
elizabeth is if it's over 250 K then you
don't need it for him he's like
everybody ever heard it's like for poor
people and people that might need the
help so he's trying to appeal to the
wealthy as well so Bernie Sanders
proposed a plan on Monday to cancel 1.6
trillion in student loans and pay for it
with a tax on Wall Street elevating the
issue obviously everyone knows about
this issue obviously not I avoid
politics well no but you know that that
everyone like student loan debt is like
insane right yeah I do know that and
that it's like bending the backs of all
these for college kids and they feel
very [ __ ] there's so many people that
come out of college and then like 10
years into their career they're still
paying their student loans and it's one
of those like even if you filed
bankruptcy there may be a compound yeah
okay it clears every other loan except
for student loans and it continues with
you right now the average student debt
is about forty thousand dollars
nationwide yeah and people are saying
that that's when the that's where the
next crash is gonna happen
so before was real estate at the bubble
right now it's student loans what would
happen well if people start not paying
their student loans because they don't
have jobs that can pay for that then
then that's where the crash is gonna
happen is if the loans that don't get
paid then the banks don't have the money
anything Bernie Sanders doing this would
like prevent that I think Bernie is just
saying stuff to get elected oh yeah I
felt it well because I mean it's a game
right like can you really pull it off
that's president I promise we will have
ice cream every five yes so didn't water
fountain right and in because I mean if
you look at the game it's Warren said
you know one thing and then she left
just enough room for Bernie to come in
and one-up her and say nah I'll [ __ ]
double
comprehend thousand dollars what hers is
like tears right it's like if you make
this much you paid this it doesn't
exactly so she says that she'll cancel
fifty thousand dollars in student loan
debt for anybody with an annual
household income under one hundred grand
and then she'll give substantial
cancellation of those between one
hundred and two hundred fifty thousand
which will be paid for by a tax on
wealthy families I like the idea of this
I think it's really cool cuz I know a
lot of people they get in huge debts
just to learn something that they want
and I also like the idea of his proposal
where it's a tax on Wall Street where I
think it was something about like a
levee or something on every single stock
traded I used to trade stocks just
[ __ ] around
and so with Scottrade you already have
to pay seven dollars a trade so I'm like
oh that's not a foreign concept so if
you could just add a dollar and if
there's thousands of trades happening a
day I think they're trying to say that
like over a course of 10 years you can
amass trillions of dollars and no one
really gets hurt there's just only $1
per trade or something I don't know well
I I did read the opposite to the counter
to that yeah and what they were
explaining is so his whole point is like
taxes speculative yes there's other
schools of thought some people are
saying just tax all trading and and for
him it's tax the speculative side that's
people who are basically speculating
that a certain currency will rise or
fall it's just an aesthetic yawn stating
like if it's like if the currency goes
in drops or if this stock drops and I'm
betting against it it's like sports
betting right I'll go up and then you
tax that but in some people are just
saying all stocks just just do that but
the other kind of stuff everything
everything that we trade every time
there's a transaction like there's gonna
be a tax on that and how that will hurt
is for example let's say you know
they're proposing a quarter of a percent
right and then they did the math it was
like let's say within a hundred thousand
dollars what is that like two hundred
fifty dollars or something right so
you're a day trader I'm a long term
investor right so that means we both pay
the same tax when you bought the stock
let's say you bought the stock that
you're about to sell to me you paid $250
I buy it from you $250 it sits in my Cal
for
ten years and then everyday you're
trading stocks at like you know 250 250
that all adds up so let's say your
stocks go down but you still owe all
those transactions and you made 10
transactions at $250 say it to him Joe
sit down this is the man who wants to do
this so you're saying right now that you
disagree no I'm just saying that there's
more to this than people blanket and try
to like generalize it's not a good
versus evil issue because I think it is
here's my thing here's my thing okay
when Wall Street [ __ ] up Fannie Mae
Freddie Mac the housing bubble guess
what we did
we printed a bunch of money yeah we
bailed them out yeah and now
everything's inflated yeah you're right
when the car dealerships [ __ ] up Ford
General Motors we bailed them out we
[ __ ] bought them and then we sold the
companies back to them for profit why
the [ __ ] can't we do the same [ __ ] for
student loans dude just print money sent
the truckload because we don't care
about dead anyway we [ __ ] go up in
debt every single day we might as well
just see how [ __ ] stretched we can
take this thing take it to the [ __ ]
limit that's what I say so you're for it
well here's what I'm against how are we
gonna pay for all these wars we're doing
in the Middle East if we're gonna be
bailing out the kids oh there's a new
tax a new tax initiative to fund this
new initiative right because we just
gave the military 1.5 trillion dollars
so we can keep on bombing people who
don't even earn $20 a day yeah which I
agree with I think it's great okay you
know thank so it's like it's one of
those things where I'm like man how like
we can do all of that we can pay for a
[ __ ] Trident missile that will not
just fry a place but it drills a mile
deep and then blows up all the bunkers
underneath there Yeah right
and then like a Jakarta missile [ __ ]
24 million dollars well then when it
comes to something like this we're all
just like yeah I don't know well for me
is it just for his presidential term or
is it something that is universal
because I actually believe in universal
education and the reason for that is
just makes the society better we have
too many [ __ ] idiots in the States
yeah so if it's like Japan right where
they focus hardcore on education and you
teach like children from you know ages
first grade to third how to become a man
of society and then everyone goes to you
know college that's way freaking
different we have a lot of [ __ ]
poverty and dumbasses in the states so
they need we need to inject more funds I
believe in that but is it just for his
term and what about all the other people
in the past that paid for their loans do
they get reparations yeah it's like
reparations right like all of us we paid
for the [ __ ] yeah those people that like
have $80,000 in debt right now yet be
dick the most because they're like what
the [ __ ] just because I'm in the wrong
generation what about the doctors in the
pharmacists and everyone who just paid
off their two-three hundred thousand
dollar loans one of the things I really
agree with with his plan is that it
doesn't allow the government to profit
off of student loans which is what's
happening right now which is insane at
that point you have to like just get
over it hypothetically like if you just
paid off your loans that sucks Society
changes and moves anyway yeah it's like
people that are in jail for marijuana
and now everyone's having dispensaries
and it's legal like if you're on that's
awful but I don't think when the goal is
to cure the debt you start thinking of
paying off the people that paid off
their debt but then you're adding to the
debt by carrying the debt that's the
counter-argument right is that there's a
gigantic amount of debt that we're
constantly accruing but isn't it for the
tax in the future to pay off the debt we
have this new Wall Street car wash that
there it's a new initiative to create
money to pay that off I guess it's not
they're not pulling from the same pool
of money
the speculation market is has no effect
on the economy is what it is it's just
gambling okay so it doesn't do any
benefits so taxing that it doesn't hurt
the economy right so people that are
saying that it will it's like how it
doesn't make sense I can see how taxing
all stock trades can [ __ ] it up yeah for
sure and why are they picking out these
groups or this group of like speculative
cuz it's high-risk [ __ ] like it's
gamblers yeah I mean why then though
well why why tax smokers more every year
like they'd kind of pick a group and
they keep picking on them because that's
not people don't care that much about it
yeah but when you say Wall Street it
already like turns sixty percent of the
people against whatever you're talking
about right like you just have to say
the words Wall Street and people like oh
yeah [ __ ] those people you know I'm
saying yeah even though a lot of people
their whole retirement is based on Wall
Street so it's one of those things where
dude there are very much two sides of
this coin it's not just a one-way street
that's a big misconception too because a
lot of people think Wall Street they
think the rich right but the rich is
like me yeah but that's like trading
less than 20% of the rich you know
majority of that is like us like normal
people or like your your parents and
people that live like working companies
and they have a 401k
that's Wall Street that's correct and
you want to tax that and hurt your own
retirement that doesn't make any sense
to me but they don't put those two
things together they just go well this
is Wall Street and [ __ ] those guys and
now it feels so good to say [ __ ] those
guys here I'm saying like it's like that
but then does it really affect us though
like I have a 401k but I'm not oh I
guess I do trade but I'm not like
trading all the time so I mean it
wouldn't affect you yeah okay so a
long-term one that you were talking
about Joe that would be G oh yes so it's
not fair for the day traders but those
are the guys that we get the stocks from
and those are the guys that keep it
going
volume volume yeah and that's a big part
of our economy too so I don't know
there's just so many layers to it that
also another thing that they're saying
is that once the universities know that
they're injecting a [ __ ] ton of money
and it's government money you're gonna
increase they're gonna increase their
prices
that's what's already happening yeah cuz
the government ensures all student loans
yeah if you think about it like the
university prices are [ __ ] expensive
I saw a comparison of the 80s and now
and even if you adjust for inflation and
all that I think one semester was 900
bucks 904 me was like cool I could get
books I could pay my tuition I was
alright and that's a university process
Cal State LA yeah so even from my tech
school stuff like when I was going I
think that program I was in it was like
twelve thousand dollars for the whole
thing it was like nine months or
something and then four years later I
find out from the students that are
coming into the hospital to intern I
asked them like how much is the program
now and they were like it doubled its
twenty four thousand twenty four
thousand that was just four years after
I did mine
I can only imagine how how much it cost
well for a four years no I'm saying like
just four years later Oh years later
yeah did you have to pull the student
loan to pay that was that broke and you
know what a lot of these loans to now
they they they're like regular personal
loans they start immediately when you
take it out OH when back in the day most
of the student loans once you graduate
you does yeah they don't go there now
cuz mine was once I graduated yeah I
mean that's why I'm saying like today
[ __ ] cuz that's how people are
graduating college with like a dance
degree with a hundred thousand dollars
in debt
cuz it all just interest just piled on
and they'll never pay it off they're
only dancing yeah it's [ __ ] up and
that's one of the argument that's one of
the arguments right one of the arguments
against all this stuff is like okay well
why not
just also cover people's rent why not
cover people's like mortgages why not
yeah there's a lot right and then when
we have by the way in the past so
there's a lot of context
[Music]
[Music]